have you ever been intimidated by an
actor and he said dinofrio but you
didn't seem intimidated by him no I
talked myself out of it it's so scary in
that role though he's great how you did
it so scary well he's supposed to be
scary but also Karen is supposed to be
Reckless right I mean in that role I'm
I'm meant to kind of like I don't get in
trouble because trouble is drawn to me
it's because I go looking for it because
I'm like I'm gonna ask the right [ __ ]
questions and that's dangerous so you
know so again the character can give you
some Swagger you know knowing knowing
that that's the attitude that comes with
it
um you know he's also not that scary
like right before that scene he asked me
if I liked his suit you know like he was
insecure about her he was you know like
oh look it's the white you know so you
know you have to remember these other
things are happening you know as it's
going on
um
I've ever been intimidated I get more
intimidated by again the social period
outside of the acting well they like me
as a person
and also think that I'm good uh once
action is called I don't know I have a
pretty good I have a pretty good Pavlov
Instinct from action to cut of of
feeling a lot Freer
I've always said this I've always been
kind of jealous of people who have
strong religion in their lives I have
never really had that because there is
this idea that like you're on a path and
someone is looking out for you and
what's meant to be is meant to be and
there's like this safety net that you
whether it's predestination or anything
like that that you can't really make a
wrong choice because it's already been
made whereas I'm out here going if I
make the wrong choice I may never have
the career I want I may not meet the
people I may not have the family I might
not have the security you know these
things so I'm constantly terrified in my
real life of taking a wrong step I'm not
much of a risk taker in my real life
but storytelling
it doesn't matter in scene three if I
cry if I yell at you if I spill water on
the floor you know you might be really
mad at me about the water on the floor
right now but if I do it in the scene it
doesn't change the fact that we have
that that doesn't change scene 40. Scene
40 still happens
so there's so much more freedom to be
brave and to make choices that are scary
because I can't change